ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE.
CALDERON CARRILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
[inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE.
TING VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHA PRODUCED.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
WHILE DRIVING DOWN TO FRESNO
THIS PAST SATURDAY.
BOB AND I WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
POSITIVE FEELINGS WE HAVE WHEN
WE SEE THE IMAGES OF HIS HOLDING
US THE DALAI LAMA.
HE ALWAYS SEEMS TO BE GREETING
THE WORLD WITH A WARM WELCOMING
SMILE.
HE EMBODIES A SENSE OF PEACE
WHILE ACTIVELY IS SUITING
KINDNESS AND A LOVE FOR ALL LIFE.
WE THEN MADE OUR USUAL STOP AT
STARBUCKS IN MANTI GO.
WHILE WAITING FOR ORDERS A
CUSTOMER WALKED IN BEING MEANING
CALLED OUT.
GOOD MORNING HOW'S EVERYONE
DOING IT'S A BEAUTIFUL DAY.
WE COULD NOT HELP THE SMILE BACK
AND CALL OUT.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
I THEN TURNED TO BOB AND ASKED
HIM.
HOW DID THAT MAKE YOU FEEL?
HE SAID OUR FIRST SURPRISE.
MANY MANY FEEL REALLY GOOD.
WE BOTH AGREED.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO BE THE
DALAI LAMA TO GREET THE WORLD
WITH A WARM WELCOMING SMILE.
AND WITH OUR POSITIVE ENERGY
LIKE THE CUSTOMER WHO GREETED US
THAT MORNING.
WE CAN ALL EXUDE ACT OF KINDNESS
AND A LOVE FOR LIFE.
AS WE HAVE OFTEN HEARD.
A SMILE COST NOTHING.
BUT IT GIVES SO MUCH.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORA AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER FLORA.
COLLEAGUES AND GUESTS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE SALUTE OUR GREAT
NATION BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE -- BOB
ISRAEL [inaudible]
OUR THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN HE'S ONLY
MET AT NINE AM ON LOWER BACK
ABOUT BAUER-KAHAN ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHEAP CLICKY DOTSON
WILSON AT THE DESK MISTER BONTA
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
OF THE READING.
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
WE ARE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IAN CALDERON.
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WENDY CARILLO.
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC LEVINE IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN HEY. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BIGELOWBURNER **** BATH
GRAYSON AND PETRIE-NORRIS TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BERNHARDT ASSN PETRIE-NORRIS IS
GUESTS WILL BE SEATED AT THEIR
DESKS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM NUMBER ONE
TEN AB SIXTY FIVE PETRIE-NORRIS
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AGAIN WITHOUT REQUEST SUCH SHALL
BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER TO THE FOLLOWING
BILLS. TO COMMITTEE AB EIGHT
SIXTY TWO KILEY FROM THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AB NINE FORTY EIGHT KALRA FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
AB TWELVE TWENTY TWO FLORA FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE AND A. B.
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT CALDERON.
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
I MOVE TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO A FINAL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION TO
HEAR AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
BONTA.
ON TUESDAY APRIL NINTH AT ONE
THIRTY PM.
MR FLORA WHAT PURPOSE SIR.
THE SPEEDWAY OBJECT AS FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE.
MR FLORA IS WITHHOLDING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
MR BONTA MOVES.
AND MR GIVES IN SECONDS THAT THE
RULES BE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLE.
MR BONTA IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND MISTER FLORA NO.
VOTE ON THE RULE SUSPENSION
MISTER FLORA NO.
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE
MEMBERS.
TAKES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS
TEN THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
AND MR VOLUNTEER AGAIN
RECOGNIZED.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO WITHDRAW IT BEFORE SIXTY TWO
RODRIGUEZ FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AN
ORDER THE BILL TO THE SECOND
READING FILE.
THE BILL IS NOT FISCAL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBER.
MS BERTHA **** BATH YOU HAVE
GUESTS ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
YES -- THANK YOU COLLEAGUES WITH
ME TODAY ARE MY CHILDREN
MONTEREY AND MAYA IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR CHILDREN THE
NEXT GENERATION TO SEE HOW LAWS
ARE MADE AND TO BE TO SEE THAT.
EVERY PERSON IF THEY TRY HARD
AND THEY HAVE THEIR HEART IN THE
RIGHT PLACE TO BE A PART OF US
SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WEAPON
THEM ON THE FLOOR
.
IN MISTER BIGELOW I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE A GUEST IN THE CHAMBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FROM MY DESK IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE KEEP YOUR
CONVERSATIONS TO A MINIMUM WE
HAVE SPECIAL GUEST WITH US TODAY.
MR BIGELOW THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO INTRODUCE A SPECIAL GUEST TO
OUR FLOOR.
STATE SENATOR BILL HANSEL FROM
THE GOOD STATE OF OREGON.
YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S A STATE
JUST TO THE NORTH OF US.
AND EIGHT HE REPRESENTS THE
TWENTY NINTH SENATORIAL DISTRICT
WHICH IS HOME TO THE BEAUTIFUL
BLUE MOUNTAINS.
OF OR AGAIN THE COLUMBIA RIVER
BASIN.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO TELL YOU HOW SPECIAL
THIS MAN IS.
BACK IN THE DAY IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HE REPRESENTED EVERY COUNTY.
IN AMERICA AS THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
SUPERVISORS.
HE REPRESENTED IN SUCH DIGNITY
AND RESPECT HE IS WELL KNOWN
ACROSS THIS NATION.
I AM SO BLESSED TO HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THEM AS
A FELLOW COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
AS WELL AS OTHERS THAT ARE HERE
MAY BE ON THE FLOOR I BELIEVE
MISTER SPEAKER WE HAVE ONE OTHER
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK AS WELL.
MR DOWN.
MISTER DALLI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR HER DESK THE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO
LIKE TO WELCOME THE SENATOR
HANSEL TO OUR CHAMBERS -- DID A
LOT OF WORK OVER THE YEARS WITH
HIM AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL.
REGARDING COUNTIES IN A THANK
YOU VERY GOOD WORK IN WELCOME TO
CALIFORNIA MY FRIEND.
AND MR BIGELOW YEAR AGAIN
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK HAVING THE SENATOR HERE.
DESERVES A GREAT ROUND OF
APPLAUSE BUT ALSO SOMEONE THAT
WE SHOULD ALSO RESPECT.
BECAUSE AS HIS DISTRICT HAS
SUFFERED IN MANY WAYS.
THE GREAT FIRES IN HIS STATE
JUST AS OURS SO WE UNDERSTAND US.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
STATE SENATOR BILL HANSEL TO OUR
FLOOR
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE OTHER GUESTS
WITH US.
ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS WHO HAS THE
I. P. IS WITH US ON THE FLOOR
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER YES
I'VE GOT SOME VERY IMPORTANT
VISITORS ON THE GET ON THE FLOOR
TODAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING MY SON DYLAN.
AND
AND MISTER FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR DESK MISTER
FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I AM VERY PLEASED TO INTRODUCE
MY FRIEND.
AND ELECTED OFFICIAL CALLING
MOSTLY CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS WHO
HAVE USED FOR CHAMBER TODAY.
COUNCILMAN HIGGINS IS A
REGISTERED NURSE ENTIRELY
SUPPORTER AN ADVOCATE. FOR THE
NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
SOCIETY.
THE COMPANY TELLS WOMAN TICKETS
TODAY IS HER HUSBAND AND BETTER
HALF.
REALLY HIGGINS.
AND ALSO ACTUALLY GILLIAM AN
ANGEL.
PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME TO THE
CAPITAL TODAY
.
AND MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MEMBERS OF
THE CAL POLY SANDERS PHONE
NUMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO
MR CUNNINGHAM IS A GUESS
INTRODUCTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING MEMBERS OF THE CAL
POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO CLASS.
YOU'RE UP IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
STAND UP SAY HI.
THEY ARE HERE FOR NATIONAL
GROCERS DAY TOMORROW SO WELCOME
THEM IN YOUR OFFICE THEY'RE
DOING RESEARCH ON THE IMPACT.
OF WHAT WE DO HERE ON THE
GROCERY MARKET IT WILL BE
BENEFICIAL TO ALL OF US IN OUR
DISTRICTS GIVE THEM A WARM
WELCOME THANK YOU.
AND MR KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
DELIGHTED TODAY TO WELCOME THREE
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT CLASSES FROM
OAK RIDGE HIGH SCHOOL IN EL
DORADO HILLS I JUST HAD THE
CHANCE TO MEET WITH THEM ASK
SOME.
REALLY GREAT QUESTIONS AND ARE
HERE TO SEE OUR LEGISLATURE AND
LEARN FROM IT FIRST HAND SO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM
TO OUR CAPITAL
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ASSEMBLY SECOND READING
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN SIXTY SEVEN
NINETY FIVE SEVENTY FOUR SEVENTY
FIVE SEVENTY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE NINETY
NINETY ONE NINETY TWO NINETY
THREE NINETY FOUR NINETY FIVE
NINETY SIX NINETY SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT NINETY NINE  1-102-103-1041. OH FIVE
ONE OH SIX ONE OF 710-810-9110
ONE ELEVEN ONE'S WEALTH. ONE
THIRTEEN ONE FOURTEEN ONE
FIFTEEN ONE SIXTEEN ONE
SEVENTEEN ONE EIGHTEEN ONE
NINETEEN ONE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE SIX THIRTY ONE TWELVE
HUNDRED WITH THE MEMONS FIVE OH
SIX WITH THE MOMENT. NINE SIXTY
TWO AT THE MOMENT 1-082-154-0113
FORTY NINE WITH THE MEMONS SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT WITH THE MOMENTS FOR
FIFTY NINE WITH THE MOMENT.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO AT THE
MOMENT TWO THIRTY WITH THE
MOMENT FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE AT THE
MOMENT. EIGHTEEN OH EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS EIGHTEEN OH NINE WITH
THE MOMENT THREE SEVENTY ONE
WITH THE MOMENTS SEVEN FORTY TWO
WITH THE MEMONS FOURTEEN SEVEN
NINE WITH THE MEMONS ELEMENTS
WHEN I'M AT THE MOMENT AND TEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE.
AHEAD IN THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE OH FIVE WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE OH FIVE AC ARE.
FIFTY EIGHT THIS IS A C. R.
FIFTY A CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER
GRAYSON FELT FOR THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS DAY.
MR GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
INTRODUCE A C. R..
FIFTY EIGHT INHONOR OF
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL OLYMPICS DAY.
SPECIAL OLYMPICS IS THE WORLD'S
LARGEST PORTS OR ORGANIZATION
FOR CHILDREN AND ADULTS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
PROVIDING YEAR ROUND TRAINING
AND COMPETITION COMPETITIONS TO
MORE THAN FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION ATHLETES AND UNIFIED
SPORTS PARTNERS IN MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY COUNTRIES.
THROUGH THE POWER OF SPORTS
CHILDREN AND ADULTS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES
DISCOVER NEW STRINGS ABILITIES
CONFIDENCE AND SUCCESS ON THE
PLAYING FIELD AND IN LIFE.
BUT SPECIAL OLYMPICS DOESN'T NOT
JUST SUPPORT THE IDT COMMUNITY
THROUGH SPORTS PROGRAMS.
IT IS ALSO THE WORLD'S LARGEST
PUBLIC HEALTH ORGANIZATION FOR
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES AND OFFERS A WIDE
RANGE OF FREE HEALTH EXAMS AND
CARE.
ADDITIONALLY AND CALIFORNIA ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY THREE SCHOOLS AND
200-100-0400 AND SEVENTY
STUDENTS BENEFIT FROM THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS UNIFIED
CHAMPION SCHOOLS PROGRAM.
IT'S AN INITIATIVE TO ENGAGE
STUDENTS WITH AND WITHOUT
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES IN
SIMILAR ACTIVITIES. 84% OF
STUDENTS WITHOUT DISABILITIES
INDICATED THAT INVOLVEMENT IN
THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS UNIFIED
CHAMPION SCHOOL PROGRAM WAS A
POSITIVE TURNING POINT IN THEIR
LIFE.
RECENTLY ARE UNITED STATES
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION PROPOSED
TO CUT ALL FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
SPECIAL OLYMPICS.
WELL NOW IT SEEMS A SPECIAL
OLYMPICS WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE FEDERAL SUPPORT.
IT IS SO VERY IMPORTANT THAT TE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS COMMUNITY NO
CALIFORNIA FOLLOWS THE
ORGANIZATIONS MOTTO CHOOSE TO
INCLUDE FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
AND RECOGNITION OF THIS
INCREDIBLE ORGANIZATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ASK FOR A FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
DAVIS GRAYSON MISTER LACKEY YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I STAND HERE AND PROUD SUPPORT
OF THE SPECIAL EFFECTS DAY -- I
WAS A SPECIAL EFFECTS COACH BACK
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR AND
HELPED ESTABLISH A TEAM IN IDAHO
THAT STILL.
IN FULL OPERATION TODAY.
CELEBRITIES OFTEN VIGILS WITH
THE ELECTORAL DISABILITIES GAIN
A SENSE OF BELONGING AND AN
ACHIEVEMENT.
AND UNITY THAT'S FOSTERED BY
THESE GAMES IS VALUABLE TO
WITNESS AND I ENCOURAGE ALL OF
YOU ON THE FLOOR. TO VOLUNTEER
AT THE THIS ANNUAL EVENT IF YOU
EVER GET THE CHANCE.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CONCORD FOR A BRING THIS TO
THE FLOOR AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
FAMOUS LACKEY MISSED FRAZIER
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR.
FIFTY EIGHT RECOGNIZING APRIL
EIGHT TWENTY TWO NINETEEN AS
SPECIAL INVESTING CALIFORNIA.
WHAT A PROUD DAY?
I SINCERELY THINK MR GRAYSON
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM CONCORD --
FOR BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION.
FOR THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS IS THE
WORLD'S PREMIER SPORTS
ORGANIZATION FOR CHILDREN AND
ADULTS WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DESCENT
DISABILITIES.
WITH SUPPORT FROM OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE THE SERVICE OLYMPICS
BROUGHT THE POWER OF UNIFIED
SPORTS TO OVER THREE HUNDRED
SCHOOLS.
IN CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR.
THIS PROGRAM BRINGS TOGETHER
ATHLETES WITH AND WITHOUT
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES TO
TRAIN AND COMPETE ON THE SAME
TEAM.
ATHLETES BILL FRIENDSHIP'S
DEVELOP CHARACTER AND LEADERSHIP.
WITH ACR FIFTY EIGHT WE
RECOGNIZE THE TREMENDOUS IMPACT
THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS AS ON
COMMUNITIES AROUND CALIFORNIA TO
INSPIRE ALL PEOPLE TO FULFILL
THEIR GREATEST POTENTIAL.
I'VE BEEN A PROUD SPECIAL
OLYMPICS VOLUNTEER FOR OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS AND I AM HONORED
TO SUPPORT.
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
RESOLUTION THE AUTHORS ASSN AT
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
MEMBERS IS FOR CO AUTHORS CAR
CLUB IN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON A C.
R..
FIFTY EIGHT THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE RATHER SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYES.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MR GRAYSON BACK
TO YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES I DO RISE AGAIN TO
RECOGNIZE.
A FEW INCREDIBLE GUEST -- FROM
THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS COMMUNITY
AT THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY.
DUSTIN PLUNKETT SPECIAL OLYMPICS
ATHLETES JUST WAVE YOUR HAND.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A FLORA
DOMINANCE.
ALSO A SPECIAL EXACTLY.
AND THEN WE HAVE DAVID SOLO
PRESIDENCY -- SPECIAL OLYMPICS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FRIENDS OR
AND THEN ALSO BILLS TO MARK --
PRESIDENCY -- SPECIAL A BIG
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PRINCE
COLLEAGUES PLEASE HELP ME JOINT
AND WELCOMING THEM TO THE
CAPITAL TODAY
.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO THE CONCURRENCE ITEM.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTY AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BURKE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO TAXATION
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MS BURKE MS BURKE
YOU MAY OPEN.
WORKING THIS BURKE YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AT AB ONE FORTY SEVEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A COMPREHENSIVE AND
BALANCED SET OF POST WAY FAIR
TAX COLLECTION RULES.
THAT MAKE SENSE FOR CONSUMER
SMALL BUSINESS AND THE STATE THE
BILL IS BACK FOR CONCURRENT AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS AMONG OTHER
THINGS THESE AMENDMENTS SPECIFY
THAT A DELIVERY NETWORK COMPANY
AS DIVINE DEFINED IS NOT A
MARKET PLACE FACILITATOR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL.
AT ADDS REFERENCE TO RELATED
PARTIES TO RANK GAMING OF
APPLICABLES THRESHOLD AND
PROVIDE AN EXPLICIT EXEMPTION
FOR NEWSPAPERS INTERNET WEBSITES
THEY DO NOW MORE THAN LIST THE
PROPERTY FOR SALE.
THIS BILL THE PRODUCT OF A
ROBUST STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO
THAT AND I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
MY PARTNER SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
IT COMMITTEE STOP CALLING.
GRENELL AND DAVID ROUGH FOR
THEIR WORK SO CLOSELY WITH ME
AND THE STAFF TO GET THIS WHERE
WE ARE TODAY WITH THAT I RECALL.
WITH RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS BURKE MISTER OVER
NOTI YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
ONE FORTY SEVEN I THINK THIS
BILL LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD
BETWEEN RETAIL BUSINESSES AND
BUSINESSES THAT SHIP INTO THE
STATE AND SO IT'S A VERY GOOD --
IDEA HOWEVER WANTED TO RISE AND
CALL ATTENTION TO WHAT I
CONSIDER A BIG IN EQUITY AND THE
WAY THE SALES TAX REVENUE IS
DISTRIBUTED AS REGARDS ONLINE
SALES AT THIS BILL IS REGULATING.
PEOPLE ARE AWARE THAT ARE SICK
CALIFORNIA SALES TAX IS
COLLECTED INTO PORTIONS IS A
STATE PORTION OF THE LOCAL
PORTION CALLED THE BRADLEY BIRDS
PORTION.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
THAT FOR AN ONLINE SALE.
THE CITY AND COUNTY THAT ARE
ENTITLED TO THE BRADLEY BURNS
PORTION DEPENDS ON THE PHYSICAL
LOCATION OF WHERE THE SALE TOOK
PLACE SO FOR RETAIL SALES IT'S
VERY CLEAR IF YOU BUY SOMETHING
A STORE HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SACRAMENTO WE'LL GET THAT
REVENUE BUT FOR AN ONLINE SALE
IT'S MUCH LESS CLEAR AND RIGHT
NOW THE WAY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LAW READS.
THE PEOPLE THAT GET THE ON THE
BARELY PRINCE PORTION OF THE
LOCAL SALES TAX IS DEPENDS ON
WHERE THEY ARE.
SHIPMENT ORIGINATES FROM NOT
WHERE TO SHIP TO SO WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS CITIES WITH LARGE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS IN THE
STATE ARE GETTING ALL OF THIS
TAX REVENUE BACK AT STARVING THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT DON'T
HAVE DISTRIBUTION CENTERS WITHIN
THEM.
SO IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR MADE A
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE ADDRESS
THIS INEQUITY WE HAVE NOT DONE
THAT YET.
BUT IT'S CAUSING TERRIBLE
BEHAVIOR WE'RE SEEING CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT ARE ENTERING INTO
AGREEMENTS WERE THE REBATE AS
MUCH AS 90% OF THAT TAX BACK TO
THESE CORPORATIONS THAT ARE
LOCATING THESE ONLINE CENTERS.
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES SO I THINK
WE REALLY NEED TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION AND GET THAT REVENUE
OUT OF THE POCKETS OF BIG
CORPORATIONS AND BACK TO THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES WHERE IT
BELONGS SO WITHOUT.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
THIS BODY TO ACT ON THIS IN THE
FUTURE.
THANK YOU MISS ROBIN ULTI SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM IS BURKE YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH I THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FOR HIS SUPPORT I ALSO LIKE TO
THINK THE SPONSOR STATE
TREASURER FIELD I'M OFF FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
ISSUE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
NAME IS BURKE AND WITH THAT THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRED ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VERY DESIRABLE.
THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALL.
TELL YOU VOTE AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN.
NOW MEMBERS WE ARE AT THE TOP OF
THE ASSEMBLY AT THIRD READING
FILE WE'RE GOING TO PASS RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS. SEVENTY ONE
THROUGH.
SEVENTY THREE AND THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTY FOUR THIS IS A C. R.
FIFTY TWO BY MS MELENDEZ CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MELENDEZ AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
THE MONTH OF THE MILITARY CHILD.
MS MELENDEZ THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER LADIES AND JOHN I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY TWO
WHICH RECOGNIZES APRIL AS THE
MONTH OF THE MILITARY CHILD.
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES AND
AROUND THE WORLD THERE ABOUT
ALMOST TWO MILLION MILITARY SONS
AND DAUGHTERS WHO SERVED THEIR
NATION ALONG WITH THEIR PARENTS
WHENEVER A PARENT IS DEPLOYED.
THE YOU KNOW THE WHOLE FAMILY
SERVICE ALONG WITH THEM AND THE
MILITARY KIDS DO BEAR THE
BURDENS OF LONG DEPLOYMENTS OF
NOT KNOWING WHEN.
THE MOTHER FATHER IS GOING TO
COME HOME OR EVEN IF THEY'RE
GOING TO COME HOME.
THEY HAVE TO SWITCH SCHOOLS
OFTEN THEY HAVE TO MAKE NEW
FRIENDS OFTEN THEY HAVE TO TRY
TO GET A DIFFERENT SPORTS TEAMS
IT'S A WHOLE NEW ENVIRONMENT.
EVERY TIME THEY MOVE AND THEY
MOVE ON AVERAGE OF I THINK IT
WAS. NINE TIMES JUST DURING
THEIR CHILDHOOD YEARS SO.
I THINK -- RECOGNIZING APRIL IS
THE MONTH OF THE MILITARY CHILD
CERTAINLY IS IN ORDER.
GIVEN THAT WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
FOR THE FREEDOMS AND LIBERTIES
THAT WE HAVE AND THAT IS BECAUSE
OF THE SERVICE OF THEIR MILITARY
PARENTS SO WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MELINDA'S -- SEE
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MS MELENDEZ WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE MEMBERS THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
EVER SINCE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SIXTY SIX CO
AUTHORS ADDED AM THAT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
WHAT A PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM?
SEVENTY FIVE THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY SIX AB. TEN THIRTEEN FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
CLICK READ WITHIN MINUTES.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTEEN WITH
A MOMENT BY SOMETHING MEMBER
OBERNOLTE.
MR OVER NOTHING ON THE MINUTES I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MAYBE
TEN THIRTEEN IMPLEMENTS A
RECOMMENDATION BY THE AUDITOR.
THAT WE DISALLOW CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST WHEN A GRANT EVALUATOR
IS EVALUATING A GRANT FROM AN
AGENCY THAT THEY WERE PREVIOUSLY
AN EMPLOYEE OR AN OFFICER OF YET
WHEN THIS BILL WAS IN COMMITTEE
I MADE A COMMITMENT TO REDUCE
THAT LIMITATION FROM A LIFETIME
BAN.
ON THIS AMENDMENT I IMPLEMENTS
THAT -- RECOMMENDATION WERE
REDUCING IT TO A MAXIMUM OF FIVE
YEARS WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH
FEDERAL LAW.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS
AND THAT THE BILL BE SENT OUT TO
PRINT AND PUT BACK ON THE FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER OVERALL THE SEE
NOTE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE AMENDMENTS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINTED
BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTY SEVEN THIS IS H. R.
TWENTY FOUR BY MISTER O'DONNELL
QUIRK READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
RELATIVE TO SCHOOL BUS DRIVER
DAY.
MR DONNA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT HR
TWENTY FOUR WHICH RECOGNIZES
APRIL TWENTY THIRD.
AS SCHOOL BUS DRIVER DAY HOW
MANY OF YOUR WROTE A SCHOOL BUS
TO SCHOOL EVERY DAY LIKE I DID.
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS IN
THE COUNTRY.
PROVIDING SERVICE TO NEARLY ONE
MILLION STUDENTS EVERY DAY
THAT'S ABOUT ONE OUT OF SIX THIS
SYSTEM IS SUPPORTED BY THE HARD
WORK AND DEDICATION OF
APPROXIMATELY. TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS
ACROSS OUR STATE.
THESE DRIVERS HAVE THOSE
STRINGENT TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
OF ANY COMMERCIAL DRIVER.
IN CALIFORNIA.
AS A RESULT SCHOOL BUSES ARE
STATISTICALLY THE SAFEST VEHICLE
ON THE ROAD BY ANY STANDARD.
BY ENSURING THE SAFE DELIVERY OF
OUR STUDENTS EACH DAY.
SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS HELP KEEP
CALIFORNIA'S PROMISE THAT EVERY
CHILD WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
EDUCATION.
THESE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
THANKING THESE PROFESSIONALS FOR
THEIR COMMITMENT TO SAFETY.
AND TRANSPORTING OUR MOST
PRECIOUS CARGO.
I ASK FOR THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION MISTER
O'DONNELL IS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
LIBERAL.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE.
THERE ARE SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS
ADDED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED AND MISTER
O'DONNELL I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
GUESTS IN THE CHAMBER.
ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME TO OUR
CHAMBERS.
PANIC DONALD AND TONI PARA GINA.
TONY PARA GREENER -- THE
PRESIDENT AND FIRST VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS HERE
JOINING US TODAY AS PART OF OUR
RECOGNITION OF SCHOOL BUS DRIVER
DAY.
IN CALIFORNIA.
GIVE THEM -- A WARM WELCOME
.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTY EIGHT AB TWO ONE TWO
CORPORATION.
AT SOME LEVEL TWO ONE TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MR BONTA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB TWO TWELVE TODAY.
CURRENT GOVERNMENT CODE IS
OUTDATED AND ONLY ALLOWS FOR
LOCAL COUNTY ASSESSOR'S AND
RECORDERS TO USE AN INEFFICIENT
AND COSTLY.
PROCESS WHEREBY DOCUMENTS ARE
PRESERVED BY MICROFILM.
AND ELECTRONIC SOLUTION IS
BETTER SUITED TO MANAGE CURRENT
NEEDS AND CAN EASILY STREAMLINE
THIS PROCEDURE THIS BILL WILL
UPDATE CURRENT LAW AND GRANT
COUNTY RECORDER'S IN ASSESSORS
THE NECESSARY FLEXIBILITY. TO
USE EXISTING FUNDS FOR NEWER
METHODS OF ESSENTIAL RECORDING
PRESERVATION LIKE CLOUD
COMPUTING STORAGE AND ELECTRONIC
DATA IMAGING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS BONTA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CAR CLUB OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
SEVENTY NINE AB [inaudible]
TWELVE CONQUERING.
A SINGLE TWELVE BY SOME REMEMBER
IRWIN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
FIRE ARMS -- WHEN YOU MAY OPEN?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT TO AB
TWELVE THIS BILL PROVIDES
JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO SET THE
TIME PERIOD FOR A G. B. R. O.
AFTER NOTICING HEARING BETWEEN
ONE TO FIVE YEARS.
THIS WILL HELP ALLEVIATE THE
BURDEN ON COURTS FAMILIES IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO CURRENTLY MUST
EXTEND TV ARE OWES ON A YEARLY
BASIS.
THE BILL ALSO MAKES TO OTHER
ADJUSTMENTS THAT MAKE TV ARE
OWES MORE EFFECTIVE I TOOK
AMENDMENTS IN COMMITTEE THAT
REMOVE THE OPPOSITION OF THE
ACLU AND PUBLIC DEFENDERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE A
THANK YOU MS IRWIN.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM [inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A
AYE AYES FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS.
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
FILE ITEMS. EIGHTY AND EIGHTY
ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
WERE FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY TWO
AB. ONE SEVENTY EIGHT BY MISTER
DALLI CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALLY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO ENERGY.
MISTER DALLI EMAIL BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I THE
BILL -- AB ONE SEVEN EIGHT WHICH
IS A NARROW EXEMPTION.
FOR FOLKS WHO LOST THEIR HOMES
DURING THE CAMPFIRE AND CAR FIRE
IN MY DISTRICT LAST YEAR.
THERE'S A REQUIREMENT THAT THEY
NEED TO HAVE SOLAR ON THEIR
HOMES THIS IS A NARROW EXEMPTION
TO EXEMPT THEM.
THEY CAN'T PUT SOLAR ON IF THEY
SO CHOOSE TO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DALLI.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE DOUBLE.
ALL MEMBERS WERE IS OUT OF OUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM EIGHTY THREE PASS AND
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR IS
A BE ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX BY MISTER
MEDINA CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN EIGHTY SIX
BY SOMETHING MEMBER MEDINA AND
OTHERS AND I PLAN TO PAWN
BROKERS.
MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AB EIGHT ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX WOULD
A JUST A LOAN SET OF FEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PAWN BROKERS.
THE CALIFORNIA PAWNBROKERS COME
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE EVERY
FIVE YEARS. TO GET LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL TO JUDGES THEIR MAXIMUM
RATES AND FEES TO OFFSET THEIR
INCREASED OPERATING COSTS.
THIS BILL HAS BARRED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE THE CLERK
WILL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU THAT I
SEVENTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY FIVE THROUGH.
EIGHTY SEVEN PASS RETAIN.
WERE FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TO OPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO SCHOOL
HEALTH.
MR BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE PRESENT A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR HEALTH RELATED PROGRAMS AND
ADVISING ON ISSUES RELATED TO
THE THE DELIVERY OF SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH.
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
ONE POORLY TREATED.
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS CAN HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE BEHAVIOR AND ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT.
AND OFFICE OF SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH PROGRAMS WOULD ASSIST
SCHOOLS TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDS AND ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS MAY
CONTINUE RECEIVING.
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AT SCHOOL SITES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE CLARK
WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NINE KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PETER IN
MEMBERS AB FIVE FOURTEEN IS A
SIMPLE AND REASONABLE STEP.
THAT SEEKS TO RATIONALLY
INCREASE THE POWER OF THE
STUDENT VOICE IN THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES.
BETWEEN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE THE STUDENT
POPULATION OF THE CSU GREW TO
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOUBLING IN SIZE.
THE STUDENT TRUSTEE EXERCISES A
CRUCIAL ROLE OF REPRESENTING ALL
STUDENTS TO THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES.
AB FIVE FOURTEEN WOULD ENABLE
THE SECOND TRUSTEE TO BE FULLY
EMPOWERED VOTING MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES BEGINNING IN
THEIR FIRST YEAR OF APPOINTMENT.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MAY.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO I SIXTY NINE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NINETY IS AB EIGHT
FIVE THREE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FIFTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID.
MS SMITH.
YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES TODAY I AM
PRESENTING ON AB EIGHT FIFTY
THREE WHICH IS SPONSORED BY
STATE TREASURER FIONA MOM.
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR
DISTRIBUTIONS FROM A SCHOLAR
SHARE COUNT TO THIRD PARTIES TO
PAY FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
EXPENSES.
OPEN AND INVEST IN SCHOLAR SHARE
ACCOUNTS TO PAY FOR COLLEGE
EXPENSES HOWEVER CURRENTLY
SCHOLAR SHARE IS NOT AUTHORIZED
TO DIRECT PAY FOR EXPENSES SUCH
AS RENT.
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR DIRECT PAY
OF THOSE TYPES OF EXPENSES
RELATED TO HIGHER EDUCATION AND
PROVIDES CLEAR AND MORE
STREAMLINED RECORDKEEPING FOR
BOTH THE TREASURER'S OFFICE AS
WELL AS THE ACCOUNT HOLDER.
AB FIFTY THREE ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS BUSINESS QUIRK SILVA.
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH YOUR FIRST
WITHOUT OBJECTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
MS QUIRK SILVA.
IS THIS YOUR FIRST BILL.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION FOR
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
INDEED THIS IS MY FIRST BILL ON
THE FLOOR AND I NOTICED IN YOUR
BILL TEXT YOU.
MENTION THE WORD GOLDEN STATE AT
TWICE UNDER THE GOLDEN STATE
SCHOLARS HERE TRUST AND UNDER
THE GOLDEN STATE SCHOLAR SURE
TRUST ACT IN THE SAME SENTENCE
YOU HAVE GOLDEN SAID STATE.
IS THAT BECAUSE YOU HAVE SUCH
GOLDEN HAIR.
ACTUALLY IN FACT IT'S NOT
RELATED TO MY HAIR AT ALL BUT
FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF FLYING BACK AND
FORTH ACROSS THIS BEAUTIFUL
STATE YOU'LL NOTICE THAT DUE TO
THE POPPY SUPER BLOOM RIGHT NOW
OUR STATE IS IN FACT GOLD AND
GOLD AND WE SHOULD.
CELEBRATE THAT EVERY OPPORTUNITY
WE GET THANK YOU.
MEMBERS NO FLAWS ON THE FLOOR
PLACE [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MISS SMITH YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THERE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTER WHO DESIRE TO THE CLARK
WELL.
CLOSE WRONG TELL YOU ABOUT I
SEVENTY KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
NINETY ONE AB SEVENTEEN BY
MEASURE SALAS CORKERY.
AS LEGAL SEVENTEEN BY SONY
MEMBER SALAS AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS.
MR SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEEKS TO
INCREASE -- AND STRENGTHEN VOTER
PROTECTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SALAS SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CAR CLUB THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES.
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS ELEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS NINETY TWO THROUGH
NINETY SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM NINETY EIGHT A.
B. SIX SIX NINE CORPORATE?
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER HOLDEN AND I PLAN
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
MR HOLDEN EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY NINE THE
BILL THAT AUTHORIZES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO USE A TYPE
OF SELDOM A TOOL CALLED AN
ASSURANCE OF VOLUNTARY
COMPLIANCE.
OR ABC FOR SHORT.
AND MULTI STATE CASES INVOLVING
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES OUR
SISTER STATES COMMONLY USE A. B.
C.'S TO SETTLE WITH DEFENDANTS
OFTEN IN CONSUMER PROTECTION IN
OR ENVIRONMENTAL ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS.
THE ABC'S ARE GENERALLY
ENFORCEABLE BY THE COURTS UNDER
THOSE OTHER STATES A. B. C.
STATUTES.
IN CALIFORNIA HOWEVER THERE IS
NO AT EXPRESS LEGAL AUTHORITY IN
CALIFORNIA LAW FOR THE AG TO
ENTER INTO ABC THAT IS
ENFORCEABLE BY THE COURT AT THE
DEFENDANT DOES NOT COMPLY WITH
THE TERMS OF THE SETTLEMENT.
WITH THE LIMITED EXCEPTION OF
TERRIBLE TRUST CASES.
SB SIX SIXTY NINE WILL HELP
STREAMLINE SETTLEMENTS IN MULTI
STATE CASES AND PREVENT
UNNECESSARY LITIGATION COSTS.
THUS ENSURING MORE EFFICIENT USE
OF THE OJ RESOURCES.
THIS BILL HAS NO NON.
NO NO NO OPPOSITION AND FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL.
DAVID.
THEY GIVE US HOLDEN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF IT IS OUT OF THAT
ALL MEMBERS OF THIS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE.
HI BUT I SIXTY KNOWS.
TO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
NINETY NINE PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE HUNDRED THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE HUNDRED A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER QUIRK
AND ACTUALLY TO HAZARDOUS WASTE.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL TOLD AT LEAST
FOR PUBLIC MEETINGS EACH YEAR.
AND AT THESE MEETINGS TO PROVIDE
AN UPDATE ON PERMITTING CLEAN UP
SITES ENFORCEMENT AND REGULATORY
ACTIVITY.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAVE
BEEN NUMEROUS LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS ON THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND WHEN THE MOST CONSISTENT
CRITICISMS OF THE DEPARTMENT IS
A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY IN HIS
DECISION MAKING.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO HOLD
PUBLIC MEETINGS AT LEAST FOUR
TIMES OF THE YEAR.
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WORK MISS SMITH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THIS BILL
IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN MY
DISTRICT WHERE THE SANTA SUSANA
FIELD LABORATORY IN SIMI VALLEY
WAS USED FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ROCKET ENGINES FROM NINETEEN
FORTY NINE ON SINCE IT CEASED
OPERATIONS IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
THERE.
IS BEEN A WANT FROM THE
COMMUNITY TO CLEAN UP WHAT IS
NOW CONSIDERED A TOXIC SITE.
CONTAMINANTS BOTH INCLUDE BOTH
RADIOACTIVE AND NON RADIOACTIVE
SUBSTANCES.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP ALL OF MY
CONSTITUENTS BUT ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN SIMI VALLEY TO GET MORE
ACCESS TO THE TSC AND TO GET
STATUS UPDATES REGARDING PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES AND THE STATUS OF
THIS CLEANUP SITE THAT DID
AFFECT THEM ALL GREATLY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
DAVID SMITH.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE ON THE BILL
[inaudible]
CIRCLE OF ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTE TO DECIDE ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF BUT I SIXTY
SEVEN KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE ON ONE IS
AB TEN SIXTY FIVE BY MISTER
BERMAN.
CARILLO.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE.
MR BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE PRESENT AB TEN
SIXTY FIVE THE BILL THAT WOULD
INDEFINITELY EXTEND THE ABILITY
OF INSURERS TO OFFER CONSUMERS
THE OPTION OF ELECTRONIC
TRANSACTIONS. FOR THEIR
INSURANCE NEEDS.
THE OPT IN APPROACH UNDER THIS
LAW PROVIDES ENHANCE CONSUMER
CHOICE FASTER DELIVERY A
PAPERLESS ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY OPTION PORTABILITY IN
THE WAKE OF DISASTERS
ACCESSIBILITY.
BECAUSE THIS INVOLVES IMPORTANT
NOTICE TO CONSUMERS THE LAW
IMPOSES ADDITIONAL SAFEGUARDS SO
THAT I MISSED EMAIL OR AN EMAIL
THAT ENDS UP CAUGHT IN THE SPAM
FILTER WILL NOT JEOPARDIZE
INSURANCE COVERAGE.
AB TEN SIXTY FIVE WOULD RETAIN
ALL CONSUMER PROTECTIONS WELL
PERMANENTLY PRESERVING THE
ABILITY FOR A CONSUMER TO CHOOSE
ELECTRONIC TRANSMISSION OF
INSURANCE DOCUMENTS.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS BERMAN SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
[inaudible]
QUIRK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS LETTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS ONE OH TO ONE
OH THREE AND ONE OH FOR PASSING
RETAIN WE'VE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEM ONE OF FIVE AND FILE ITEMS.
ONE OH SIX AND ONE OH SEVEN PASS
AND RETAIN WE ARE MOVING TO
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CITY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE CARD
FOR READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN TWENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ABOUT THIS IS THE CONSENT.
CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS IS CONSENT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED ASIDE ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
TALLY THE VOTE.
HI THIS IS SEVENTY KNOWS ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
AND THE COVERAGE THE REMAINING
ITEM ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL [inaudible]
TWELVE NINETY TWO FIVE SEVENTY
NO.
ZERO MEMBERS MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSIONS
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
APRIL NINTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY APRIL TENTH CHECK IN
SESSION AND THURSDAY APRIL TENTH.
FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEE HERE NO FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN MISTER BONTA MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS AT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED.
UNTIL THURSDAY APRIL ELEVENTH AT
NINE AM IN THE QUORUM CALLS
LIFTED